the Kurdish LED Syrian democratic forces
are holding out in rows aligned using
tunnels and trenches to mount their
defense it's been just over a week since
the turkey led military operation began
the battle here is key if that operation
is to succeed fighting has been fierce
the fighters are mainly from the Syrian
Kurdish YPG group that make up the bulk
of the SDF forces Turkey considers it a
terrorist organization this border town
is where turkey wants to create what it
calls a safe zone that will stretch 30
kilometers into Syrian territory the
United States which not only abandon the
SDF and pulled its troops out of
Northeast Syria is demanding a ceasefire
it has already imposed sanctions on
Turkey as a form of pressure but
President Recep Tayyip Erdogan who will
receive a u.s. delegation led by Vice
President Mike Pence on Thursday is not
budging our offer which takes effect
immediately all the terrorists needs to
lay down their arms destroy their
fortifications they built and withdraw
from the safe zone from managed to
Eureka border that we will establish
then our offensive will be finished so
400 kilometers of border has been
secured turkey launched the operation
with two objectives to push the YPG from
the border at least 30 kilometers south
and to create the zone that will allow
Syrian refugees to return
the US is now out of the way but Russia
stepped in deploying its troops on
frontlines in a clear message to Turkey
Moscow has called turkeys operation in
Syria unacceptable and it seems it now
wants its military presence in Syria to
end Ankara does have strong cards
particularly the role it can play in
helping reach a political settlement the
Syria's war process and a new government
is being formed we will handle all areas
in Syria including offering and northern
aleppo we are only reconstructing and
rebuilding these areas Russia has not
shied away from publicly criticizing
turkey for its incursion into Syria
describing it as unacceptable and
demanding it to be limited in time and
scale Russia insists turkey has the
right under an agreement reached with
Damascus in 1998 to push up to a maximum
of 10 kilometers into Syria to conduct
anti-terrorism operations but officials
insist the Adhan attack does not allow
turkey to remain in Syria permanently
and Moscow won't accept that russia's
Foreign Minister Sergei Lavrov explained
what would be acceptable security
cooperation between Turkish and Syrian
army's along the border cooperation with
the Syrian regime would be a radical
shift for Turkey but there is a new
reality government troops are back in
the north for the first time in years
unprecedented as well has been Russia's
position and criticism of Turkey there
will be hard bargaining ahead senator al
jazeera on the turkish-syrian border